did you guys show this calendar yet you
want me to show this this Riley Gaines
on the cover it's beautiful it's
beautiful cover look at that she's like
not even Photoshop she looks like
photoshoop and real life love it that's
awesome and I love Seth that you said
how you explained that we need to focus
on buying products that are made in
America but are also America owned
because anheiser bush is it's in St
Louis but it's a Belgian owned company
now yeah it was sold to inbev and
there's people that have contacted me
and be like yo I work for anheiser Bush
I work in America it's an American thing
and it's like yeah but it's not own it's
a it's a foreign company now It's Made
In America which means a portion of all
those sales is going to Europe correct
now one thing I would like to say on the
show real quick if you are a chain
director and you have a chain director
experience in the beverage industry
specifically alcohol but the beverage
industry in general we are looking for
someone and that is a hard job to find
because you have to have someone that
has experience in that so I'm going to
take this moment to like you know ask
that if you're a chain director have
that experience reach out to me on
Twitter at South weathers if you have no
experience in that I love you but don't
apply